hello and welcome to the plane just one
guitar yeah that's a relatively frequent
opponent but I haven't played him so
much recently I've got eight games um
what I come on maybe some other news
online I don't want to have though all
those weaknesses hit into the same wish
again yeah sometimes feels a little bit
tough this line on the white player and
sitting there have all those weaknesses
maybe play something super solid here
right it's actually not that solid we'll
see at least with my knowledge it's not
solid let's see if 4 and 0 this is
getting rather sharp and oh interesting
be 60 and this position
okay I mean I was thinking that the
diagonal is open there but doesn't seem
to be anything great possible
yeah black is black is fine i can go 90
for you and tim start to to trade things
yeah i just wanted to play oops sorry my
mouse wheel wanted to play something
else in the same issue always stuck with
that non porn structure hit that line
but Quincy to is just something that I'm
no one general grounds but not in some
very detailed way okay I can just go
nitey for as I said I can take on c3 and
play it should be for things like that
are possible maybe also Queenie 7
yeah that's definitely a possibility and
now you can go nitey 40 be sure before i
was thinking night before actually it
looked better to me but maybe I'm wrong
here I'm pretty happy with them with the
bishops even though there are ya more
more traits coming up it seems and ok to
play here I think maybe but maybe Queen
f4 or something like that getting the
Queen out of the D file yeah thats it
seems fine asking black about his bone
structure if he wants to really go Queen
to e7 probably prob sorry probably
possible yeah I'm so taking on f6 Queen
takes that kind of ending is probably
okay for him
yeah but it's tough to do something else
actually
it was my idea maybe I can still try a
little bit because of the week and um
square on c6 it is not great or anything
but
right d 8 that's probably good ok this
one
ok so it doesn't seem to mind that I
play before and then nights is six ok
I'm doing that neither son oh there ok
anyway the night that is pretty good it
restricts a rook coming to the aid and
the knight on e4 doesn't have that many
squares I'm actually am I not
threatening f3 miss going oaks CA de
this is the thing ok and so I have to
play for b 5f 395 h4 strapping the night
but he had rook c8 so I have to go away
for first ok here i can take and try to
do something against the porn 94
since seven Brooksie seven looks good
threatens night is six and Rudy seven
that looks a little bit stronger than
roxy five
so what now group 27 9 24 9 p-5 hmm ok I
guess I have to she's still holding this
night Teague's we can be a drupe c7 496
still we'll get counterplay time morning
with Ruger on the second unfortunately
check cannot cover it really this is a
very very annoying
I don't see a good movie even wow that's
bad check check check
14 seconds sheriff meet or something
here check check I can actually take
check there was a chicken chetrit check
check check check check mate its mate
who I was pretty scrappy at the end yeah
I had to operate with very little that
and actually was happy to to get
somewhere a little bit but then it was
it was too still difficult yeah I don't
think I have much in this opening at all
d5 yeah I don't I don't know yeah that's
also what what the engine wants to play
maybe that was the relatively best that
I could that I could get a bit surprised
by some some of his moves there that you
actually allowed this because here I'm
starting to press a little bit with the
knight on c6 the computer thinks it's
equal is this okay 8 and yeah probably
probably what can black hair hold but
it's a bit it's a bit annoying yeah and
here and this seems to hold according to
the comp this this just keeping the
night down and it looks a bit awkward to
go into that pin but probably I'm I
cannot attack c3 in some meaningful way
at least this is what the engine is
claiming
so here I'm I'm slightly better I rugby
7s stronger actually just win that that
porn but that's not that's not so bad
but here it was it was awful somehow I
mean I didn't have a clear a clear way
forward check check check the engine was
kiss me / advantage but check probably
it's it seems to be a draw yeah I mean
it's important I mean I didn't even see
that but it's at five now check this
engenders win and check otherwise I'm
I'm checkmated him chan chan chan to had
to had to be very quick there yeah at
the end it was a very very scrappy a
kind of kind of end game with no time on
both sides okay well thanks for watching